doo-doo-doo-doo on the lady in Aisle
takes a cool day prey
[Music]
[Music]
nice
[Music]
got to run
[Music]
[Applause]
what you've only right here's where we
both to us pray
I was definitely folks when your feet
[Music]
and change places hi guys I am back
after my old trip away from releasing
sweater and I just need to say at the
very beginning thank you thank you thank
you so much to everyone who has bought
sweater who has listened to sweater who
has streamed sweater who has sent me
lovely messages who are just enjoying
what I have been working so hard
throughout the past like three or so
years to put out and also amount to
thank you to everyone who was there
along the way who helped with the
production horizon Productions who
helped with the filming who helped with
my mental stability I couldn't have done
it without any of you guys and honestly
it's a dream come true and I'm still
like reeling from just how awesome how
awesome it is to have it out there and
finish so in today's video I just as
well as thanking you I want to take you
through kind of the process behind
making the EP some meanings behind each
of the songs that you'll find on there
and also just to let you know that you
can actually buy it for yourself with
this hand made EP cover and it's
cardboard so you know sustainable
recyclable way yeah so it's it's
available to buy on Etsy of course
because I have hand painted them all
handcrafted it there are only ten up
there right now but if demand calls for
it I can make more but right now it's an
exclusive deal just 10 lucky people will
have them thank you to all my patreon
and for those of you in that tier you
got your albums a while ago or your EPS
you're physically piece I don't know the
words terminology you got your discs so
I really hope you've been enjoying them
and thank you to everyone who sent me a
picture of you with those discs it was
freaking cool to see
you just get them and enjoy them on the
disk also is a bonus track and that
bonus track is actually the first song
that I ever have recorded in my bedroom
so it might not sound too the same
quality as the other songs and that's
because it's literally just me trying to
learn the ukulele singing a silly song
about feeling like an alien because
someone we all go through moments where
we feel like we don't belong right and
we've just been plopped onto this earth
and what the hell are we doing here and
you'll only hear that song on the
physical EPS if you want to buy your own
copy of sweater that it is on Etsy and
the link is in the description below so
this took three whole years to to make
from start to finish and that seems like
a long time for three songs and well it
is because we were making it alongside
my University where I was also making a
game as well but this is more of a
passion project what I see my music as
it's just a way for me to express myself
when I feel I need to be expressed
and that's exactly what sweater is
that's what the EP is it's me in my most
vulnerable state just opening up and
hopefully making something that you guys
can relate to can listen to can enjoy
I'm so so fortunate to have been working
with Jamie from Horizon productions he
is so talented so talented when he
reached out to me he was primarily
working on rock songs and I don't know
if you've noticed but my thought exactly
rock but what he did with the songs that
I had created by myself my ukulele it's
just mind-blowing I just give so much
credit to that guy and he's even
branching out to two other different
genres now so I would say please check
in the description below for a link to
him and his
I can't wait forever I'm not that
patient I've got too many things to do I
knew from the beginning that this EP had
to be called it's better because sweater
is a song that people have known for a
long time it was one of the first ones
that I wrote played and showed to you
guys and you guys seem to resonate with
it and everyone who I've paid it for
even though it's such a simple song and
honesty you guys could play it it's so
simple so easy but I think that's what I
love about it because I've already seen
some people cover it and they send me it
and it's so sweet
anyone can sing it and also the meaning
I feel can be relate to a lot of
different people a lot of just different
scenarios so I want to talk to you about
the meaning behind each song but I won't
go too in depth because I still want you
to to make your own assumptions and to
to feel like you can relate to it in
some way or another but sweater this
song is about
kind of reaching out to someone or
having a connection with somebody who
makes you feel nice who makes you feel
warm and lovely however maybe right now
is not the right time to commit or to
break things further or perhaps there's
other circumstances involved that you
know this can't go any further than what
it already is so it's kind of about
appreciating someone and a scenario some
situation for what it is in the moment
instead of expecting it to be something
bigger as I think of a lot of times we
we find people or scenarios and we want
it to be something bigger and we're
holding on to that and we have high
expectations for it and that actually
ruins the moment that we are creating
right there and then and it could
potentially damage any future that you
have with that person or in that
situation so it's all about kind of
living in the now and realizing that
even though something right now makes
you happy you can also be happy on your
own or in another situation you you
aren't attached to that but you're able
to enjoy the beauty that
is presented to you in the moment the
music video it shows me singing in a
white room very plain room and then I
wore a green screen jumper which was
bloody that was the hardest thing to
edit I green jumper green screen easy
it's like it's just a key on Premiere
Pro right it's just you just driving and
drop no oh my gosh that's but most of my
time editing was just spent trying to
get that green screen right and I know I
know it's not perfect okay
but hopefully it brings a bit of charm
to it because it's not perfect but I've
tried I tried my best the story is there
that I'm basically wearing my heart on
my sleeve for you guys I am naked if you
would see it that way because you're
being able to see straight through me
into my experiences into a place where I
feel most myself and that I love and
that is the forest and I'm being chased
by my past by people in my past by
memories but I'm not scared of them you
learn to love and appreciate what
hardships you went through to make you
who you are today I'm not gonna say a
better person but it's who you are today
very chilled an interesting one and it's
the worst one on the EP it's it's one
that took Jamie and I a long time to get
right because it means a lot to me and
therefore I don't want to talk about it
to him depth but it was a song that I
wrote and I didn't even realize what I
was writing it about it was about
hardships in my past that I went through
that made me have to realize where my
strengths lied and also where my
weaknesses lied and it's basically about
me and where I retreat to whenever I
feel I can't do something I feel
uncomfortable and that's behind my brave
face essentially I wanted brave face to
be a lot more war than the other songs
on the track I wanted to feel very
wishy-washy kind of like you were inside
my mind hence why you have that kind of
eerie feel to it that you will know when
you listen to it this is just the story
of a girl who's so de hurt now she's
forgotten she's gone and then fresh
start is the newest
track away I'm not really proud of that
one it fend from me actually wanted to
just tell a story through my music
because I do enjoy writing little
stories as well so I wanted it to sound
like I was telling you guys a story and
like I had a protagonist and I was
talking about something in in particular
the way that I see it is that there's
this little shadowy guy who's like all
shady like I'll buy your heart and I can
give you this and opens up his trench
coat that's kind of how I viewed it but
obviously it has a bigger meaning than
just that as I was writing it it was
about a girl who couldn't handle hat
anymore couldn't handle damage couldn't
handle sadness because we all get
through those times where we just feel
like it's too much and we'd rather just
become a robot we'd rather just become
just soulless and not feel anything
would be better than feeling what you're
feeling right now however if we were to
give that away then we wouldn't
appreciate the good times that come we
wouldn't be able to to understand what
it's like to to feel happy to feel sad
to form bonds with other people too to
have importance around things that that
we love and that resonate with us
so sometimes we just need to accept that
we are going to get upset and be down
and be okay with that because at the end
of the day you can't live without a
heart not human beings not as human
beings if we give that away we we give
ourselves away and we become nothing so
that's kind of what the hot ones about
but yeah I hope you enjoyed this little
deep dive into the behind the scenes of
the EP I will be making more music
because I freaking love it and why not
just do things that you love please do
subscribe and follow for more music you
can also follow me on Instagram I put up
a lot of videos of me just in my pajamas
singing if in my room so if you want to
see videos like that it's a wee more so
on my Instagram there's more content to
come
you might notice I've been away for a
while and that's because I've moved
house again there's a lot of things to
catch you up on and we'll do that in
another video but you will see this face
more often till then listen to sweater
if you want it you don't have to but
thank you for doing it okay
when I go down have low easy or evening
and thanks again
I
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there are some sweater